the past few minutes President Trump
responded to the latest threats from
North Korea with a new tweet president
said quote Kim jong-un of North Korea
who is obviously a madman who doesn't
mind starving or killing his people will
be tested like never before exclamation
point this tweet comes just hours after
the Trump administration announced tough
new sanctions against North Korea major
Garrett is in Somerset New Jersey that's
here where the president is staying
today major good morning good morning
the Trump administration is trying to
give banks and businesses around the
world and especially in China a stark
economic ultimatum going forward if you
do business with North Korea you will
lose all access to US banks financial
markets and trade the order targets only
one country and that country is North
Korea appearing with the leaders of
South Korea and Japan president Trump
said his new executive order is aimed at
choking off the revenue fueling North
Korea's accelerated pursuit of
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
advanced nuclear weapons the regime can
no longer count on others to facilitate
its trade and banking activities the
sanctions move is unilateral and does
not have United Nations backing assigned
Security Council nations like Russia and
China were not ready to sign on it was
also a clear indication the white house
wants the world to see it's trying
non-military options the order targets
countries individuals and businesses
that provide goods services and
technology to North Korea it is
unacceptable that others financially
support this criminal rogue regime it
also cuts off access to US banks it
allows the u.s. to freeze assets of
anyone dealing with North Korea's
textile fishing and manufacturing
sectors UN Ambassador nikki Haley if
they don't have the funding for the
ballistic missiles for the nuclear
production then they can do less of it
President Trump said China ordered its
banks to cease doing business with North
Korea that is a somewhat unexpected move
and we appreciate it
Treasury secretary Steve minuchin tipped
off leaders of China's central bank
before the
was signed and we appreciate the
relationship with China and we look
forward to working with them China said
it opposes all unilateral sanctions and
disagreed with the president's
declaration that it had shut down all
business deals with North Korea China
recently placed sharp new limits on
future deals with the North viana China
facing increased pressure major thank
you